25% of a bottle of Tahin, 10% of a bottle of Papa's Pilar, 95% of a bottle of Michter's
straight rye whiskey, 90% of a bottle of Redwood Empire, half of a bottle of Aradura
Silver tequila, 1 liter, half of a bottle of Colonel E.H. Taylor, 80% of a bottle of
Windstorm Cabernet Sauvignon, 1 bottle of Canoe Ridge Merlot, 1 bottle of Gearbox Pinot
Noir, 75% of a bottle of Gearbox Pinot Noir, 75% of a bottle of Aperol, 60% of a bottle
of Fireball, 1 bottle of Jack Daniels, 10% of a bottle of Maker's Mark, 80% of a bottle
of Tankeray, 40% of a bottle of Woodford, 15% of a bottle of Crown Royal, 1 bottle
of Hendrick's Gin, 70% of a bottle of Farmer's Gin, 35% of a bottle of Casamigos Blanco,
80% of a bottle of Yahweh Jalapeno tequila, 30% of a bottle of Milagro Silver, half of
a bottle of Crop Organic Cucumber Vodka, 5% of a bottle of Caravella Limoncillo, 30%
of a bottle of Boll's Elderflower Liqueur, half of a bottle of Mr. Boston's Blue Curacao,
1 bottle of Wheatley's Vodka, 10% of a bottle of Tullamore Dew, 60% of a bottle of Peach
Knops, 40% of a bottle of Grey Goose, 1 liter bottle, half of a bottle of Meyer's Original
Dark Rum, 25% of a bottle of Siete Mysterios Mezcal, 10% of a bottle of Yahweh Coconut
Tequila, half of a bottle of Pueblo Viejo Tequila, 70% of a bottle of Parrot Bay Coconut
Rum, 85% of a bottle of Parrot Bay White Rum, 50% of a bottle of Jim Beam, 75% of a bottle
of Tito's, 10% of a bottle of Wheatley's.
33 Michelob Ultras, 14 athletic non-alcoholic beers, 8 Yinglings, 1 High-Rise Blue Bear
Cherry, 26 Coors Lights, 18 Miller Lights, 21 Pacificos,
4 High Noon Watermelons, 4 High Noon Pineapples, 5 more High Noon Watermelons,
2 bottles of Marca de Caceres Cava Brute, 2 bottles of 30A Rose,
2 bottles of Scarpetta Pinot Grigio, 1 bottle of Windstorm Chardonnay, 1 bottle of Squealing
Pig Sauvignon Blanc, 1 more bottle of Windstorm Chardonnay, 2 more bottles of Scarpetta,
1 more bottle of Squealing Pig, 1 more bottle of Windstorm Chardonnay,
half of a bottle of Jägermeister, full bottle of Mojito Mix, 1 bottle of Squealing Pig,
1 bottle of Scarpetta, 1 bottle of Windstorm Chardonnay, 1 more bottle of
30A Chardonnay, 1 bottle of Charles de Fair Brute,
1 bottle of Margarita Mix, 75% of a bottle of, scratch that, 2 bottles of watermelon
melon mix.